Petroleum-based plastics may soon be a thing
of the past thanks to shrimp.
You heard that right.
Hey Everyone, I'm Dr. Carin Bondar 'Biologist
with a Twist'.
I'm a guest on DNews today, visiting from
my usual haunts at the Science Channel and
Scientific American.
and I'm rather tickled to be here!
Today we are talking about an amazing new
bioplastic that comes from a rather unlikely
source.
Shrimp.
They are beloved by humans world-wide.
Shrimp kabobs, shrimp rings, shrimp creole,
lemon shrimp, coconut shrimp, shrimp gumbo...you
get the picture.
All of this gluttonous shrimp consumption
leaves us with whole lot of discarded shrimp
shells - and researchers at Harvard's Wyss
Institute have discovered a way to put them
to great use.
The shells, or exoskeletons of the shrimp
are largely composed of a material called
chitin - the second most abundant organic
material on the planet (next to cellulose).
This is because all arthropods, including
marine crustaceans like shrimp and crabs,
but also insects, beetles and butterflies
have exoskeletons that contain chitin.
Keep in mind that arthropods are the MOST
abundant animals on the planet, they account
for over 80% of all known animal species.
So as far as the availability of chitin as
a source material for bioplastic - we would
never run out.
Chitosan is a material derived from chitin
and is the basis for this new bio-plastic.
The technology is a significant improvement
on previous bio-plastics that are made with
cellulose, a plant-based polysaccharide.
These cellulose versions are greener because
they aren't created from petroleum.
But their uses are limited and they require
very specific environmental conditions to
degrade.
So why is chitosan better?
Although researchers have known about the
potential applications of chitin for several
decades, they were held back by the processing
techniques, none of which could produce chitin
objects that were strong enough for everyday
use.
However, cutting edge techniques have now
been developed to change all that.
Newly formed chitosan is proving to be tough
enough to be mass-manufactured into complex
3-D shapes using traditional casting or injection
molding techniques.
Chitosan products will be as durable as traditional
plastic toys, dishes and other everyday items.
It can also be used in the manufacture of
garbage bags, packaging materials and even
diapers!
Once discarded, the chitosan-based material
breaks down in just a few weeks.
And if that wasn't good news enough - as it
degrades it also releases rich nutrients that
support plant growth.
It's like the cherry on the sundae of a huge
environmental win.
When we consider that americans generate over
34 million tons of plastic waste every year,
and that less than 7% of that waste is recovered
for recycling - the need for a sustainable
bioplastic is extremely huge.
Consider the 100 million tons of plastic debris
that is currently floating in the Pacific
Ocean, strangling, suffocating and starving
wildlife on massive scales.
Chitosan bioplastic has the potential to change
the way we interact with our planet and the
animals we share it with.
It's development could really change the world.
So which manufacturing industries do you think
would be a great fit for chitosan?
What do you think would be better made with
bioplastic?
Leave your ideas in the comments below.
and Hey! what do shrimp have in common with
goblin sharks?
well, not much actually, except that a shrimp
trawler in Florida recently brought up some
seriously ghoulish bycatch.
You can watch my video about that over on
Animalist News, and be sure to subscribe here
for more DNews!